Did you know that evil alien invaders
are coming in November? Yeah, that's
what we're being told by the mainstream
media news. We've been talking about
this for years now. that we know that
there is an agenda, a satanic agenda to
make the world believe that there are
alien visitors and that there's good
aliens and there's bad aliens and that
the good aliens are going to come at a
time of great calamity. When there's
earthquakes and disasters and pandemics
and all this stuff going on in the
world, then the cosmic saviors, our
cosmic brothers and sisters are going to
come at just the right time when the
world needs a savior. And they're going
to say, "Hey, we've come to help. We've
been disarming nukes for years. We've
been watching you. We've been trying to
protect you. We've actually been living
among you for years and you didn't even
know it because we've been watching you
just trying to help you, protect you,
guide you, just like they said in the
Marvel Eternals movie, right? All
predictive programming telling us. And
then once they gain our trust, once
these demons in disguise masquerading as
visitors from other worlds gain our
trust, then they're going to say, "You
know what? We're actually here for a
much bigger mission.
We are here to help you in a war that's
coming because an evil alien invader is
coming to take over Earth. And if you
don't side with us, demons, you're never
going to survive. Guess who the evil
alien invader is? None other than Christ
with all his angels. When you read just
the Bible, you cannot fall for all these
deceptions, all the propaganda, all the
predictive programming. When you read
the Bible alone, who is coming to earth
to destroy it? Christ alone. Who is the
one that's trying to save earth, quote
unquote, save earth? Satan. When he
rounds the militaries of the world to
fight against Christ. If you're not on
Christ's side, you will be destroyed by
the brightness of his coming. But if
you're on his side, you will be changed
in the moment in a twinkle of an eye and
be we will put on immortality and we'll
be caught up to meet the Lord in the
air.
So all this propaganda, all these movies
that come out,
something's coming. It's an asteroid.
It's Thanos. It's the evil alien
invaders. We must put aside all our
differences and band together and and
fight against this war, this final war,
because it's us against them. minutes.
Humanity is going to be destroyed. It's
all satanic propaganda. Every single
movie is the same movie. There's a new
Marvel show or movie or something coming
out with uh the the thing. It's the
Fantastic 4, I guess, and a Silver
Surfer looking woman that's announcing
that she's the herald for this being
that's going to destroy the Earth. It's
always the same thing over and over. But
check it out. This is mainstream media
news. Unilad shocking new study reveals
possible hostile alien threat could be
attacking Earth in a few months. That
was just nine hours ago. A group of
scientists claim a possible a possibly
hostile alien threat could wreak havoc
on our home planet before the end of the
year.
New York Post. Possibly hostile alien
threat detected an unknown interstellar
object. A shocking new study claims a
mysterious intergalactic object could
potentially be a hostile alien
spacecraft that's slated to attack our
planet in November. Do you see that
right there? In November. It goes on to
say, here's the picture that they have
of the potentially hostile craft that's
coming towards Earth.
And it says, I don't know if you can see
this. Let me zoom in. Okay. So, right
here it says, "Comet
three
atlas streaks across a a dense star
field in this image captured by the
Gemini North Telescope, Gemini
Multiobject Specttograph, July 2025."
This just came out hours ago, guys.
Dubbed three atlas, the interstellar
entity entity interesting was discovered
on July 1st, rocketing towards the sun
at more than 130,000 mph, live science
reported. Less than 24 hours later, it
was confirmed to be an interstellar
object with initial observations
suggesting that it could be a comet that
measures up to 15 miles in diameter,
larger than Manhattan. However, in the
new paper, the trio of researchers
suggest that it might be a piece of
extraterrestrial spy technology in
disguise.
So, either way, it's always propaganda
that something is coming. How many times
has the news told us that there's an
asteroid, there's a meteor that's coming
so close to Earth, it might wipe us out.
It's it's always this fear propaganda.
Fear propaganda. Put the fear in people
because why? because they need an excuse
to build weapons pointed towards the
heavens. And they've done it. Star
Force, we that came out Trump's first
term right after uh the the pandemic
happened. There was the big legislation,
the over 5,000 pages that said in the
COVID relief legislation plan booklet,
they said, "We want to know everything
you know about UFOs." I don't know what
in the world UFOs have to do with a
pandemic, but it was in there.
And months later, D, Star Force, we are
now defending Earth against
space threats. And and recently, Trump
said, uh, I'm going to build a golden
dome over America. And we might include
Canada if they're lucky, but we're we're
protecting ourselves from outside
threats, even threats from outer space.
They've been saying this stuff over and
over. And if they didn't put out the the
fear propaganda, the asteroids and the
UFOs and all that stuff, we'd be like,
"Why are you wasting money? Why are you
making a space force? Why are you making
a a golden dome over a country?" But all
the fear, all the movies, all the news,
and it never happens.
Oh man, I just want to go like all into
this. Space exploration is fake. We got
videos on this. Everything that NASA
does, all this ISS stuff, it's all
proven to be fake. There's nothing going
on out there. And yet they keep pushing
it. There's something coming because
Satan has a plan. Satan has an agenda to
unite the world in a sense of false
religion and false unity to battle
against the second coming of Christ.
This is all prophetic. We're going to
get into that. So remember the name of
this thing was called Atlas, right? It
said three eye atlas. So what is Atlas?
Why is there a connection? What is this
atlas thing? Um, according to mythology,
who is the first king of Atlantis? Is
what I asked Google. And it says,
according to Plato's dialogues, the
first king of Atlantis was Atlas.
So Atlas, the name of this spaceship
that's coming towards us is the the name
of the first king of Atlantis. Why is
that important? Well, a lot of things
have been coming out lately from Trump's
mouth about the Golden Age. We're in the
Golden Age. And so I asked, how does
Atlantis connect with the Golden Age?
The connection between Atlantis and the
Golden Age lies in the portrayal of
Atlantis as a once great civilization
that experienced a period of prosperity,
wisdom, and harmony, often referred to
as the golden age before ultimately
suffering a decline and destruction.
This narrative positions Atlantis as a
metaphor for a lost utopia, highlighting
both the potential for human achievement
and the dangers of corruption and moral
decay. So, Atlantis is kind of this
parable of you can reach this golden age
where there's a a pinnacle of wisdom and
technology, but then you could fall
right after that because of a moral
decay. moral decay. Remember that
because we've been talking a lot about
prophecy, where this is all headed with
politics and religion joining together,
politics and religion joining together
to form the one world religion. How are
you going to get everyone to join
together in a one world religion? Well,
you have to make it abundantly obvious
that there is some kind of moral decay
going on in our society. And we can see
that. you just turn on the news and you
see, you know, black versus white and
red versus blue and let's throw bricks
and all this stuff. Um, gender
confusion, all this stuff is the moral
decay that's happening. But now Trump,
he's like the savior, right? He's going
to he's going to end this thing. We're
going into the golden age.
So remember these connections, golden
age, Aquarius, Atlantis. Um, remember
the golden age and Aquarius go hand in
hand. So we we all remember Trump saying
this right here.
>> This will truly be the golden age of
America. That's what we have to know.
>> So Trump's openly announcing we're we're
going into the golden age, right? So
what is the golden age? The golden age
is the age of Aquarius talked about by
these esoterics like Alice Bailey and uh
Helena Bavlotssky and all that. And
we're going to get into that. But right
now, I asked the question, does Atlantis
connect with a star? Actually, I asked
Atlas, not Atlantis. Atlas is a member
of the Plleades, an open star cluster
located within the Taurus constellation.
So, Plleades,
does that ring a bell?
The Plleadenss. I asked the question,
will the Plleadenss help humans fight in
a war against evil aliens? Because I'm
I'm always seeing these ads for uh Gaia
and all this stuff and they're saying,
"Oh, the Plleadenss. They're living
among us. You might even be one. How to
find out if you are a Plleadian." And
all this stuff, right? Because there's a
new age belief about star people. Some
of Star people are aliens that live
among humanity and they look human and
the only way you can know is if you just
you feel like an alien. I've always felt
like an alien. I might be a Plleadian.
And so it says focus on spiritual
guidance. The prevailing view is that
Plleadenss considered highly evolved
spiritual beings from the Plleades star
cluster aim to guide humanity.
Aim to guide humanity towards higher
consciousness. Love and unity.
Interesting. Love and unity makes you
think of peace and safety, right? Whoa.
Love. Love and peace and safety, bro.
According to Gaia,
there are thought to off they are
thought to offer wisdom and support for
spiritual growth rather than engaging in
physical battles or intervening directly
in human affairs. So the plleadenss who
live among us, I'm not saying I believe
this stuff, guys. Uh I do believe that
demons live among us and that quote
unquote aliens are nothing but demons in
disguise. I hope you guys have already
gathered that from what I've said so
far. But these quote unquote plleadenss
are here to guide us into a higher
consciousness. Bro, we got to we got to
reach those good vibes of love and unity
because man, there's too much division.
And what causes the division? The
mainstream media, the propaganda. We all
were getting along just fine until, you
know, BLM came along and let's tear down
statues and let's throw bricks and let's
cause chaos because it's all
programming. It's all brainwashing. It's
a system that's causing the masses to
follow along like whatever's on the TV
screen is reality and you need to get
involved and you need to be a part of
something right and get involved in the
war. And so this is what who the
plleadenss are. They are here to bring
us to a higher consciousness. Um we've
talked about Chris Bledsoe before and
this guy who's a openly professed
Christian who says he believes that
Jesus Christ is our Lord and Savior. He
believes in the Trinity and uh he he
used to be a Baptist, but now he's a
Pentecostal, but he will tell you 100%
he's a Bible believing Christian. Now,
he had an experience that happened to
him, I think in 2012 or so where some
UFO came down, knocked him to the
ground, and he was actually healed of
his Crohn's disease. And so his son saw
the same thing. And his son was
terrified and said, "These things are
demons." And he said, "No, son. They're
good angels. They healed me." See, he
didn't test the spirits. He just fell
for the lying signs and wonders, the
miracle working demons that the Bible
talks about. That many in the latter
days, many will depart from the faith,
giving heed to seducing spirits and
doctrines of demons, these miracle
working demons. In the last days,
Satan's going to be performing miracles,
lying signs, and wonders when he appears
as Christ himself, a supernatural being
that we've never seen in our life. And
millions of Christians are going to fall
for this because we've never been faced
with a deception so great. because
Christians aren't opening their Bibles
and reading the order of prophecy. We
think we're going to be sucked out of
here before uh before tribulation comes
or we there's so much confusion about
prophecy and doctrine and everything.
But if we understood that Satan is going
to come first, the counterfeit, the the
deceptive one, the antichrist will come
before Christ returns. And when Christ
returns, he's not going to set his foot
on the ground. He says when they say I'm
in the secret chambers, don't go. And
they say in the desert, don't even go
look.
But that's what's going to happen.
Satan's going to appear as Christ. And
so he has these interactions with a
woman called Hathor and that is a
Egyptian goddess, but he interprets her
as the Holy Spirit. Because again,
unity, we have to all come together in
belief system. So when heathen deities
start to manifest into our world, like
Alice Bailey and Elena Botszky have said
that the these ascended masters are
going to manifest into our world. We're
going to have to rethink everything. And
so many people are going to say, "Look,
whether you were Babylonian, Egyptian,
Buddhist, Christian, we're all seeing
the same thing. It's all pointing to
God. You you interpret this as Hatheror,
but I interpret it as the Holy Spirit.
you interpret it as uh raw and Krishna,
but it's it's Yahweh. We're all believe
in the same thing. We just we have
different ways of of translating it or
interpreting it, right? That's what the
Pope said before he died. He said that
all religions are pointing to the same
religion. It's just like different
languages to God. I wish I would have
threw that clip in here. Now, listen to
what he says. He says that the Hathor
lady had a prophecy about 20 about
Easter 2026.
And this happened back in like 2013, he
said. But he said that she's going to
come to uh give this prophecy about 2026
about a shift in consciousness. Check
this out. The lady explained to me that
in April of 26 there would be an
alignment where this star of which is a
blue star of Regulus appears on the
horizon in front of the Spinx and it
would be red.
>> And you know what? This is right.
>> That's what she said. She's spoken to
astronomers. This is the phenomenal
thing about this.
>> And she said it'll be red. And when that
happens, it would mark a shift into a
new knowledge, not an apocalypse. That's
what she told me. It doesn't mean Jesus
is coming back. There's a new knowledge
that's coming. What is that? Is it under
the pyramids? They've discovered
something. Is it the Hall of Records? Is
it
disclosure?
>> Is it disclosure? See, on another
podcast, he said for the he said, "I'm
saying this for the first time ever. I
believe that Easter of 2026 could be the
second coming of Christ, but apparently
this interview with News Nation was
after that." And he said, "She told me
it's not the second coming of Christ.
It's new knowledge,
a shift in consciousness, and that it
could be disclosure. Alien disclosure
happening in April of 2026 is what this
guy's saying." So, I'm telling you, 2025
is like the beginning of the end. Like,
we're starting to see crazy things
happening that we never saw before.
Spiritual things, apparitions more and
more. We're starting to see, you know,
oh, I saw Jesus and it has to be real
because he had eyes of fire and all this
stuff. People don't understand that
Satan can transform himself into an
angel of light. that he can appear as a
a beautiful memerizing serpent in the
garden that's so deceptive he can make
an unfalling an unfallen being like Eve
fall
and we think we're smarter and we think
oh it has to be of God because he called
himself Jesus well Satan can't appear as
Jesus yeah he most certainly can he can
appear as what we believe Jesus looks
like and so I asked did Alice Bailey
call the age of Aquarius the golden age.
And it says Bayailey's writings focused
on the age of Aquarius, which is where
we're at now. She said it would happen
in 2025. The externalization of the
hierarchy would happen in 2025.
It says Alice Bailey's focus on the age
of Aquarius as a period of significant
evolutionary and spiritual change,
new knowledge, right? A new higher
consciousness, all this stuff. This is
what the Plleadenss are supposed to be
bringing in. This is what Chris Bledsoe
is saying that Hatheror is saying is
going to happen. And Alice Bailey said
in 2025 would be the age of Aquarius
when this would happen. Now am I saying
we should put all our our trust in
prophecies from the esoteric? No. But I
know that Satan has a plan and he's
telling his people his plan. While God
has his prophecies in the Bible, Satan
has his plans through the esoteric and
in 2025 is supposed to be this
evolutionary spiritual shift marked by a
shift from individual to group
consciousness to group consciousness.
Now, we've never lived in a time where
we are so connected. I mean, AI, 5G,
Neurolink, all this stuff. We've never
been so connected ever in history. And
it just so happens that we are merging
ourselves with technology to the point
where we can actually be in a group
consciousness, a hive mind. We can
actually reach that place right now. We
are here
increased understanding and the
development of right human relations.
She described it as a time for the
externalization of the hierarchy. That's
right there. That means that spiritual
beings are going to manifest into our
world in the year 2025. A concept
related to the manifestation of
spiritual beings and their influence on
humanity. Spiritual beings and their
influence on humanity. What did we just
see about the Plleadenss?
They are
spiritual beings. They have spiritual
focus. Um it says they have telepathic
communication. They're not saviors or or
deities. It says it's important to
understand that these belief systems
plleadenss are not considered saviors or
deities to be worshiped. Rather, they
are seen as guides who empower humans to
rem to reclaim their spiritual
sovereignty and create more harmonious
existence. This is exactly what what
Alice Bailey is saying. The term the
golden age is more often a general term
associated with a utopian vision of a
future era and peace, prosperity and
spiritual harmony, bro. Unity coexist
movement, one world religion, spiritual
harmony often appearing in various
spiritual traditions and popular new age
discourse. What does the Bible say about
truth?
Truth divides. He Jesus said, "I'm not
coming to bring peace. I'm coming to
bring a sword of division that mother
will turn against daughter and and
father against son and truth divides."
We're not promised anywhere in the Bible
anything about some perfect harmony of
belief system or some kind of worldwide
revival. It's not in there. Now, a false
revival, yes, many will depart from the
faith, giving heed to seducing spirits
and doctrines of demons. Why? because of
the lying signs and wonders, the miracle
working demons that are going forth to
the kings of the whole world and
gathering them together to battle
against the second coming of Christ.
That's the only unity we're seeing is
with demonic forces, not with Christian
belief system. So I asked, did Elena
Bolivatsky refer to the golden age as
the age of Aquarius? And it says she did
foresee a period of significant
spiritual and mental evolution. again
spiritual mental evolution associated
with the shift into the Aquarian age.
She likened the transition to a coming
golden age with the end of the kali yuga
iron age in Hindu cosmology anticipating
a renewal and rebirth following a period
of significant change. She connected
this with the expansion of higher mind,
bro, and a shift in humanity's psychic
characteristics.
So, both these esoteric
channelers are saying the same thing
that in the year 2025 or in the age of
Aquarius, which is there's a kind of a
spectrum of when the age of Aquarius is
supposed to happen. Some people thought
2020, but anywhere between 2020, 2026,
something like that.
Alice Bailey straight up said 2025 would
be the externalization of the hierarchy.
The age of Aquarius is about
mental and spiritual evolution and unity
and peace and love and higher vibes and
all that stuff. Right
now there's a book called the raw
material. Not the raw, the raw. This is
the Egyptian deity. And notice it says
the law of one. This is book one. the
raw material. There's many books and it
says by raw and humble messenger of the
law of one. It is this is a book that is
chneled writings from a woman who is
channeling raw an alien entity she says
and it and it's saying unveiling the
secrets of their arrival and their
imminent return. This book poses
important questions about the role they
played in the formation of past and
present civilizations. So they're our
gods. They created us. Their involvement
in the creation of monumental
antiquities through two two decades of
rigorous experimentation
with telepathy. The authors have
unlocked the doors to communication with
these extraterrestrial beings,
culminating in a breakthrough contact
that is chronicled in this volume.
With over 200 pages featuring sessions,
sessions are chneled writings. Uh
sessions 1 through 26. Readers will gain
unique insight into the cosmic scheme of
things and learn about other beings that
inhabit our universe. Join us as we
embark on a quest for knowledge and
unravel the mis mysterious mysteries of
our existence. I want to see if they
openly admit that these are chneled
writings. Um it's not hard to find if
you Well, here you see. Look at this.
She's got her eyes covered. She's laying
down. It says the circle of one. After
dawn lights the candle and incense, he
and I walk the circle of one around
Carla. Carla is the one that's
channeling and repeat the words that
begin each contact. This was June 98 uh
1982.
Love vibrations, bro. When the session
is over, Dawn waits a few moments for
Carla to return to her usual quiet,
stiff body. He calls her name a few
times until she responds, helps her sit
up, rubs her neck a bit, and gives her a
gives her the chalice full of water to
drink after he and I filled it as full
as our love vibrations as we can. What
in the world? That's not so as full of
water or love vibrations. Now, look,
notice what's at the top of her head.
There's a a table here with an open
book, a chalice, and a candle. That book
is the Bible. She has the Bible above
her head. She's channeling an alien
named Raw and she's getting all these
channelneled messages that were written
down and and performed in front of a
live audience even. So, I'm not going to
take time to read this whole book. So, I
asked Chat GBT, are you familiar with
this book? Does this book say anything
about the Ten Commandments or anything
of that nature, the Bible? And it says
in session 16, the origin of the ten
commandments. Oh, this should be
interesting. So raw, this
extraterrestrial raw who's being
channeled is going to tell us where the
ten commandments actually came from,
where their origins came from. Question,
can you tell me the origin of the ten
commandments? Raw says the origin of
these commandments follows the law of
negative entities. Wait a minute. Whoa.
negative entities
gave the ten commandments
impressing information upon positively
oriented mind body spirit complexes
complexes the information attempted to
copy or ape positivity while retaining
negative characteristics now this what's
being quoted here this is raw this is
the entity raw being channeled and this
is what he says are the origins of the
ten commandments They came from some
negative entities. Notice right here,
negative entities.
It says question, was this done by the
Orion group?
This is correct. Ross says this is
correct. The Orion group in according to
this these channelneled writings, the
Orion group are a evil alien race. And
it says, what is their purpose in doing
this? Ross says the purpose of the Orion
group is conquest and enslavement.
Conquest and enslavement. The ones that
gave the Ten Commandments to Moses are
these evil aliens who are here for
conquest and enslavement. This is done
by finding and establishing an elite and
causing others to serve the elite
through various devices such as laws you
mention and other and others given by
this entity. Uh I'm not going to keep
reading all this stuff but basically
Orion influence on religion. Yes, they
they transmitted distort distorted
spiritual teachings and rituals. Ten
Commandments origin said to be impressed
by Orion unto Moses positive oriented
mind. Purpose behind it to establish
control elites and submission via
codified laws. Broader religious
imprint. The Orion group strategically
infiltrated hierarchical hierarchical
religious systems. So, these beings from
Orion, I think that's interesting.
Uh, I'm not going to get into that, but
I do think it's interesting that the
beings from Orion that are coming to
Earth to bring the Ten Commandments are
these evil alien invaders.
And I think this all ties in. All this
stuff's been going on since the 80s and
before. And now we see that the news is
saying there is an evil alien invader, a
hostile alien threat coming to Earth.
And it's all about we need to unite
together.
Look, we've been we've been so uh set
against each other. There's been so many
wars and oppression and disagreements.
And you know what? It's time. It's time
for peace. You know what? That's why we
have all these earthquakes and and
famines and pestilences. It's judgments
of God because we are not uniting
together in love. So, look, man, if
you're if you're a Buddhist or a
newager, I I know you're a little
different than me, but we're we're both
on the right path, right? We're both
seeking after God and love. So, let's
just hug each other and hold hands and
sing kumbaya.
I want to show you that this comes
straight from the book of Revelation.
Revelation 16 verse 13 says, "And I saw
three unclean spirits like frogs." Think
about what an alien gray looks like.
They look like frogs come out of the
mouth of the dragon, out of the mouth of
the beast, and out of the mouth of the
false prophet. For they are the spirits
of devils working miracles.
These devils are going to work miracles
and deceive the entire world. And then
they're going to go forth unto the kings
of the earth and the whole world to
gather them to that battle of the great
day of God Almighty. And then it says,
"Behold, I come as a thief." So right
after this, Christ is coming. I mean,
these unclean spirits like frogs,
they're gathering the world together.
They're getting the armies together.
Space Force, uh, Golden Age, Golden
Dome, all this stuff. The stage is being
set for Satan to unite the world in a
false peace and safety. We hear it right
from Trump's mouth. Peace and safety,
golden age, all this stuff. And it's all
lining up with esoteric writings. It's
all lining up with the Bible. Prophecy
is coming true right before our very
eyes. The news is telling us that
science scientists are saying that uh an
alien threat is coming in November.
Time is running out, guys. Is the church
asleep right now? Are we the 10 sleeping
virgins right now? It's time to wake up.
It's time to trim your lamps, have
enough oil, and be ready for the wedding
of Christ. Be ready for his soon return.
He's coming like a thief in the night.
Are you ready? It's time to stop playing
games. It's time to start taking your
relationship seriously. Get in God's
word daily. Pray without ceasing. Ask
for discernment. Ask for spiritual
wisdom and eyes to see because there is
a deception coming like none other.
Nobody in the history of the world has
ever faced a deception like we are about
to face. Adam and Eve fell. Perfect
beings in a perfect world fell because
of one memerizing serpent.
What about supernatural beings,
heathen deities manifesting in our
world? We're going to have to rethink
everything. We're going to see lying
signs and wonders and miracles like
we've never seen in our life. Are you
ready for that? I'm questioning myself.
God's given me eyes to see this stuff.
And I'm still terrified of the deception
that's soon to come. More so than the
persecution, at least the persecution.
You endure to the end and you get a
crown of life when you get to the other
side. But the deception
believing that Satan is literally Christ
because we don't understand Bible
prophecy and because we're not praying
earnestly seeking for truth and wisdom
and spiritual discernment and eyes to
see. If you were blessed by this, please
give it a thumbs up. It really helps
this video get into the algorithm. I'm
pleading with you guys. This is vital
information. The signs of the times are
are just happening all around us. The
Bible is true. God is real. Jesus is
coming and all our family and friends
need to know this truth. If you're new
to this channel, please subscribe. If
you'd like to support this channel, you
can do so by going to candidruth.org. We
got Cash App, Vinmozelle,
PayPal. We even have Patreon. If you
like buying cool merchandise, we have
awesome t-shirts and hoodies and mugs
that that uh have scripture and just
encourage people to use their brain in a
time when all the propaganda is saying
you don't want to use your brain. You
don't want to be a nerd. You want to be
the the cool guy that gets the chick,
right? We love you guys. We cannot do
this without you. I hope this was eye
openening. Please share this with all
your family and friends and we'll see
you next time on Candid Truth.